c'est le retour d'un ancien combattant
de ceux qui ne lâchent jamais la sphère
pouvait pas trouver mieux que notre dame
du ve l'abbaye du cotentin fondée par
mathilde l'an perez la petite fille de
guillaume le conquérant
c'est ici que tron pour quelques
semaines
le chef-d'oeuvre de judicaël l'épopée de
guillaume librement inspirée d'une
tapisserie dit de bayeux 66 m elle avait
là la tapisserie le temps qu'il fait à
peu près la même longueur quant à son
épaisseur historique
elle est indéniable et inutile d'en
vanter la qualité technique il s'agit
d'une acrylique sur moquette ultra
résistante aux outrages du temps
la preuve nous en suivons les aventures
depuis les années 80 ici c'était sur un
immeuble très en vue de la ville de caen
la première expo que j'avais faite donc
c'était au musée de coutances et là il y
avait beaucoup d'enfants qui étaient
venues et notamment sur le livre d'or
une fois j'ai vu comme ça maintenant que
j'ai vu cela je vais voir la vraie la
sienne est tout aussi personnelle que
celles de mathilde c'est du brutal mais
attention pas de l'art brut lui se
classe plus volontiers dans la
figuration libre
ils se sont d'ailleurs tellement libre
qu'il peint comme il respire
au point aujourd'hui de se sentir un peu
envahis par sa peinture
je ne sais pas pas faire de toute ma
production l aidant je me suis obligé
d'acheter un immeuble tout ça pour
pouvoir entreposer pas ce que c'est
qu'une partie ça ah oui allofs
c'est énorme
et comme tout artiste il se réjouit
évidemment quand ces oeuvres reviennent
à la lumière surtout celle de paris si
on n'est pas prophète dans son pays
j'ai plus de succès entre guillemets
ailleurs que qui chauffe